[Musique]
78 ans plus tard ils n'ont rien oublié
pour les survivants et leur descendants
l'horreur des camps de concentration est
toujours présente la douleur encore vive
[Applaudissements]
je t'aime depuis 2005 le 27 janvier est
officiellement reconnu comme la journée
internationale de commémoration en
mémoire des 6 millions de victimes de
l'Holocauste
de voir de mémoire observée partout dans
le monde comment l'Ukraine par le
président wolozimir zalinski lui-même de
confession juive
une journée solennel au pays également à
Ottawa politicien et leader religieux
ont souligné l'importance de ce jour à
jamais gravé dans l'histoire mais aussi
de la nécessité de combattre les
discours haineux encore présents
aujourd'hui que ce soit en ligne ou en
public on doit faire preuve d'une
vigilance absolue face à la haine et
face aux propos antisémites racistes ou
haineux de toutes sortes
[Musique]
ces quatre frères et soeurs de Winnipeg
sont âgés de 96 à 101 ans il constitue
la plus vieille fratrie du survivant de
l'Holocauste toujours de ce monde
ils ont été déportés en Russie durant la
Deuxième Guerre mondiale si leurs
conditions de vie est extrêmement
difficile ils ont tout de même survécu
les autres membres de leur famille
envoyés dans des campes concentration
dont petit frère n'ont pas eu cette
chance lui laisse ta famille
pour eux leur descendants et tous les
autres qui ont vécu ces êtres cités le
devoir de mémoire n'a rien de symbolique
souligner l'importance de cette journée
demeure capitale ici Mathieu Gohier
Radio-Canada